right so we were talking about
i was going to say when it comes to the
transgender movement it's now being
pushed in schools
right
and how do we feel about
transgenderism being pushed on children
it's ridiculous
like children don't need to i mean
children can feel however they alvarez
they want to speak into the mind but
children's minds change they're not
mentally capable to make any decisions
about their bodies in a long time i feel
like it's ridiculous i feel like it may
be helpful for
acceptance
of you know
the society you know maybe to educate
them a little bit but
i feel like it's going to do more harm
than good
but what gets me annoyed about is that
kids are struggling to read and write
and do basic arithmetic and stuff like
that but yeah we're spending all our
time teaching about relationships at
such a such a young age you know and
stuff like that i think let kids enjoy
their childhood yeah you know at some
point it has to be at some point when
they're about maybe
10 11 12 they talk about what happens in
life some people identify as gay some
people identify as lesbian people as
trans
you know but you still have to respect
them if you don't agree with them teach
about diplomacy about just because you
disagree with someone doesn't mean that
you disagree doesn't mean that you
disagree are bored that you want them
cancelled and know how to tolerate one
another but now we're just teaching oh
someone identifies this
is what it's going to be i remember this
though and this confession i'm going to
make i remember when i was a kid
i saw want to identify as michael
jackson
yeah yeah
which version was very i wanted to be
him so if i had been different from
faith so
you're in good company yeah but if that
was the case does that mean that i had
to bleach my skin
and um pull my hair yeah charlie is
closer to my work michael jackson
young michael yeah but my parents would
have said i would tell my parents mom if
you don't allow me to bleach my skin and
pearl my hair you're being unloving and
i did think i was michael jackson when i
was five but like anything else you grow
out of it yeah yeah i think me
personally i think when it comes to
teaching young people about this
i think
as much as teachers can say they're
neutral and they're not biased i feel a
lot of times the teaching will come
across as encouragement rather than
actual education and it's like
young young people can be very very
easily influenced if a child like a
child can see something on tv they're
thinking oh yeah that's true that looks
great if they go into school they see
okay um perhaps um i would look better
as a man yeah you know what that's
actually true maybe i would yeah let me
put on a wig oh yeah i put on my mum's
wig and it worked out really really well
like yeah i think i should do that i
feel like that there there would be a
line between actual education and
encouragement and it's hard to balance
that line so yeah yeah another thing
that happens is when someone does
identify themselves as trans the child
they get so much ammunition
admiration that it feels their ego
exactly so for example if i was a
five-year-old or six-year-old then okay
i'm a girl now all of a sudden
everyone's saying you're so brave you're
this bbc is contacting you obama's
contacting you everyone the prime
minister's contact you say how brave you
are all of a sudden now that goes into
your head you figure well he got the
information maybe i should do it it's a
social contagion
yeah yeah it makes sense
called libs of tick tock yes i have yes
no you never come across that she got
she got she recently got docked
absolutely fantastic so far could you
say that again
libs of tick tock
l-i-b-s l-i-b-s of tick-tock architect
because
what they do is they kind of aggregate a
lot of videos that people post
basically it's transgender teachers
going to school confessing that they
have come out to their school kids and
how it was a euphoric experience for
them and how the kids have got their
pronouns correct and how some of their
kids have crossed them now and said they
want to be transgender and i think to
myself
did they think that before you said that
because the way i look at it is
uh which one of you here said that kids
are impressionable
you you're absolutely spot on i'm a dad
sarah's a dad we're gonna chat about
this like off camera before i walked in
the room
and
i think that
when screaming it it is in a way it is
in a way i don't think it's like i don't
i actually don't think it's that
malicious actually i think that some
some people like the worst one because i
think the sheep's clothing malicious
because you're coming across as very
loving giving to sweeties but you know
yeah trojan horse kind of medicine yeah
yeah it is even worse yeah but the thing
is i i've got no problem with people
being lesbian girl bisexual because i
can
i can understand that in my mind it's
basic physical attraction
relationship dynamics we all know how
they work
but when you can't explain something and
you tell a kid that's normal
and the kid believes that postman pat is
real at the same time
where are you going with this
conversation with the child yeah you
know when i was a kid i love power
rangers
you know what i mean it was a plush show
right
i was a black power ranger
yeah i was a red one yeah but the point
is that when when you listen when you
watch these shows as a kid you kind of
get engrossed in the imagination of it
all you do yes and if you would let your
kid cross the road on their own go to
the shop on their own yes you know they
kind of wipe their bum on their own yeah
can they really transition and
i want to ask you guys a question is is
it child abuse it's true is it child
abuse because you're implanting thoughts
into their head when they're
impressionable because as a child you
see every adult as a god figure anything
they say has to be true i remember my
mum saying to me that if i don't sleep
at eight o'clock some
deep uh thing available will come and um
you know torture me that gave me
nightmares yeah so so imagine says oh
because you like teddy bears oh you're
like i like care bears by the way when i
was a kid confession does that mean
you're very
oh you like care bears do you maybe
you're a girl
and i'm saying maybe i am
so i'm saying how impressionable you are
you're right i think it's grooming
yeah yeah i think joe rogan said it
didn't he but i think some of these
people actually think they're doing
something good which is which is where
you get that i mean you get the debate
when they actually feel they're doing
something positive to help children
when i don't see it as a positive in any
way shape or form well the thing is you
talk about children there are two people
that i want to talk about specifically
that actually have trans children right
so
um
dwyane wade
dwyane wade is a is an nba basketballer
his son has now transitioned into a girl
and i forget her name but his name her
name see i'm offending people already um
his name her name she's transitioned to
a girl and also charlie's thuron
charlie saron um
adopted a boy
from somewhere in africa
and she said at the age of five or six
he said to her
i don't feel like a uh
a boy mommy i feel like i'm a girl and
now if you were to look at pictures of
when she adopted him as to
now he's a whole he's a whole girl right
and this is like she's got him in like
blonde wigs and all and all kinds of
stuff do you know what i mean so um the
trans
child thing is also um a thing and it's
like they're allowing children
to make decisions at such a young age
that are going to affect the rest of
their lives and now it's like how do we
allow a child to make such a decision
it's very harmful yeah i don't think you
do but i do think there should be
room left for queerness i think i think
it was you who mentioned earlier where
you said
if a child consistently like persists
that this is how they believe and if as
they grow older they grow in that unease
then that's a different thing um and i
think there should be room and scope for
them to allow them to explore who they
are um
but i don't think it's fair that young
people actually make that decision yeah
as a child exactly i mean i believe it's
harmful actually just imagine how how
many questions a kid actually grow in
their minds when you add so much
confusion in it like by just bringing
this topic which is transgenderism right
they would just have more questions to
ask they would get even more confused
today i feel like a girl tomorrow i feel
like a guy how like just because i like
pink for example they would be like oh
yeah today i'm a girl tomorrow night i
would like for example powering just no
i'm a guy you know it's just like it's
it's different it's like you you grow
more confusion into a kid they're not in
a position to take decisions like that
that's why bring back home schooling
baby
there's so much that
the kids have access to that they're
going to find it out about it and have
their own
idea about it so i don't think it should
be taught
in school because of it just being
everywhere for them to have access to
and you may never know if a kid is being
homeschooled how they search up their
answers for their homework or
information for their homework they may
see something pop up and then go down a
rabbit hole of
society's own thoughts of whatever it is
that they're looking up so i don't think
that
there's no way of hiding anything from
kids nowadays unless you they're not in
touch with the outside world at all so
they're going to find out about it some
way or another
yes it is
it is a dilemma because if you become an
authoritarian parent and literally block
everything off
sooner or later once they turn 16
they're gonna rebel exactly the same you
find that with very very conservative
parents who raised their kids very
conservatively they become the biggest
rebellion because they just feel now i'm
free exactly yeah it's funny you talk
about conservatives though um do you
think that this quote unquote
this whole trans thing
is a conservative
or liberal
thing
it's definitely left wing it's 100
definitely a liberal thing but yeah it
could be like for example what tends to
happen i think there's cycles that
things happen so for example if you're
too conservative like for example your
parents are too conservative
your offspring will probably be liberal
very liberal extra liberal to the point
whereby i think it's gen z
uh thought to be the most conservative
people because they're thinking this is
becoming really really out of correct
yeah so what will happen is i think
we're probably going to have a wave of
ultra conservatism in the next
50 years or so because there's only so
much
you can divide a
um
break a line to before it becomes
ridiculous you know so we need to talk
when you talk about trans racialism and
and everything so yeah so i actually do
think there is hope that
at some point this is just ridiculous
now so i think it's i think it's neither
i feel like
i feel like as
i feel like the human race
the idea of thought
and curiosity or even feelings like you
said everybody has feelings in every
walk of life right i don't think i think
we're limiting what we're talking about
to western society i'm pretty sure i
don't know but like probability states
that there's somewhere in africa or
middle east or wherever there will be an
individual who wakes up every day
feeling like the opposite sex
irrespective of conservative liberty i'm
trying to say i feel i don't want to say
it's natural i don't want to say that
but i can see
an individual just getting there without
influence or just this because talking
about feelings but then just like anyone
had the feelings of feeling like michael
jackson
i think i think you you posed an ins you
posed an interesting point when you were
talking about authoritarian parents yeah
i think for the parents watching this
they might actually be very confused how
how would how would we recommend they go
about
their children that may be going through
this in a way that's supportive rather
than harmful because if they are too
authoritarian and they're like actually
no no you can't do this absolutely not
like you said there will be that
that over control will lead to over
rebellion
so
how but at the same time if you're too
if you if you're too lenient and whatnot
that there can be so much damage and
harm in that as well so how do parents
go about it i think give them one second
give them statistics yeah if they're a
good question
age where they can understand you know
basic maths and you know can percentages
and things like that
um
89 of people that go through
transitioning regret it
yeah and the suicide rate is heavy in
that in that demographic as well
so if you put it like that yeah you know
it's that's that's not even like a
debate it's not like a brexit vote 52-48
that is conclusive that this is a bad
idea for you so if that's what the
figures show because i like i like
analytics i think that they play a big
part in how you can make big decisions
um
i think that would be a good way to kind
of say to kids look so just be direct
one in three people who uh trans have
attempted to commit suicide according
according to the statistics
but to answer your question as human
beings and like anyone says no matter
how much how rational we think we are
we're more emotional than we are
rational oh yeah so i'm saying from from
that perspective you better speak for
yourself
[Laughter]
so um
to answer your question alexa there's a
good question what do you do in that
situation
don't do anything that will have a
long-term consequence like puberty
blockers if it's a situation whereby
my
boy wants to wear dresses
mates probably let them wear the dress
because at least you know in your head
there's not going to be no long-term
consequences on their body but if you
give them puberty blockers yeah i can
make them fertile that is things so that
would be my advice so don't you think
that it's very interesting that you're
allowed to to let children
make long-term life decisions but these
children can't even vote on what's going
on in their country yeah
yeah you know i mean because that's an
interesting point you've made there
because when you were talking about the
ultra conservatism you think is to come
in the next 50 years yeah if you
actually gave children the vote say 16
year olds upwards this country would be
left wing country because you'd find
that most people that go to university
now
are all
crazy left they're not even just like
center left they're crazy left